This would be our solution, great work if you found it. We want to start by
finding the lowest common denominator, so we should factor each of these
denominators. We factored this denominator to be m plus 1 times m minus 5. This
denominator, we'll need to use factoring by grouping. You need to find factors
of 30 that sum to negative 13. Those factors are negative 3 and negative 10.
They multiply to give us positive 30, and they add or sum to give us negative
13. We use our factoring tree method to get this lowest common denominator. We
multiply our first fraction by the missing factor of two m minus three, whereas
we multiply our second fraction by the missing factor of m plus one. And
remember, we're really just multiplying by a one here and a one here. We're
changing these fractions into equivalent forms. We distribute m to 2m minus 3 to
get the first numerator, 2m squared minus 3m. Next, we distribute the negative 3
to the m plus 1. We'll get negative 3m and negative 3. Now, we want to add the
two numerators together and keep our denominator the same. The like terms in
these numerators are negative 3m and negative 3m. So we have 2 m squared, minus
6 m, and minus 3. Finally we want to check to see if this is factor able. We
want to find factors of -6, that's sum to -6. Well there are no factor pairs of
-6 that sum to you -6. So we're finished. So really subtracting rational
expressions is not that different from adding them. We just want to make sure we
remember to distribute the negative sign.